this Net Zero goal it won't happen
because it can't happen the constraints
we live in a world Freddy it's defined
by networks we live in a world of a
network of networks right we don't think
about it much but I've ridden the tube
here and it's just amazing right well
the network of systems that are
connecting there whether it's part of
the electric grid and the rail systems
and the rail workers and the Personnel
that maintain that system in trucks and
cranes and overhead rigging and all
these other things that work together so
this idea that we're suddenly going to
change the entire under pinning of the
modern global economy which runs 80% on
hydrocarbons coal oil and natural gas
and do so in you know 30 years it's
Madness